and you did uh build with AMD recently
that I saw uh how does the uh uh the the
7900 XTX compared to the RTX 4090 or
4080. well let's start with the fact
that the 7900 xdx kernel drivers don't
work and if you run demo apps and Loops
it panics the kernel
okay so if this is a software issue
Lisa Sue responded to my email
oh I reached out I was like this is you
know
really
like I understand if you're 7x7
transposed Winograd com is slower than
nvidia's but literally when I run demo
apps in a loop the kernel panics
so just adding that Loop
yeah I just I just literally took their
demo apps and wrote like while true
semicolon do the app semicolon done in a
bunch of screens right this is like like
the most primitive fuzz testing why do
you think that is they're just not
seeing a market in the in um machine
learning they're changing they're trying
to change they're trying to change and I
had a pretty positive interaction with
it this week last week I went on YouTube
I was just like that's it I give up on
AMD like this is their driver doesn't
inflate I'm not gonna I'm not gonna you
know I'll go with Intel gpus right Intel
gpus have better drivers
so you're kind of spearheading the
diversification of uh gpus yeah and I'd
like to extend that diversification to
everything I'd like to diversify the
right the more
my central thesis about the world is
there's things that centralize power and
they're bad and there's things that
decentralized power and they're good
everything I can do to help decentralize
power I'd like to do
so you're really worried about the
centralization of Nvidia that's
interesting and you don't have a
fundamental hope for the the
proliferation of Asics
uh except in the cloud
I'd like to help them with software no
actually there's only the only Asic that
is remotely successful is Google's TPU
and the only reason that's successful is
because Google wrote a machine learning
framework
I I think that you have to write a
competitive machine learning framework
in order to be able to build an Asic
you think meta with pytorch builds a
competitor I hope so they have one they
have an internal One internal I mean uh
public facing with a nice Cloud
interface and so on
I don't want a cloud you don't like
Cloud I don't like Cloud what do you
think is the fundamental limitation of
cloud fundamental limitation to cloud is
who owns the uh the off switch so that's
the power to the people yeah and you
don't you don't like the man to have all
the power exactly all right
and right now the only way to do that is
with the Nvidia gpus if you want
performance and stability
interesting it's uh it's a cost of the
investment emotionally to go with amds